- Oh, damn it.
Come on man.
He thinks that's happening.
- I love pizza, okay, there I said it.
I love pizza so much that
I'm wearing it today.
As you can see, it's a
beautiful day in New York
so I thought it's the perfect day
to track down something
I saw on Instagram.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Fucking kidding me?
This is what happens when the two types
of food make sweet,
sweet love to each other
and have a baby.
Cheeseburger and pizza.
And of course this pizza comes
from Vinnie's in Brooklyn,
which at this point
is basically pizzeria crossed
with a mad scientist's laboratory.
Now I wouldn't dare go
on this journey by myself
so I'm gonna grab a friend.
- Cheeseburger pizza.
Right now?
Just let me finish.
Okay, just, just.
- So I just knocked Jade out of her chair
which is not a good look but.
(upbeat music)
- We are off the subway
headed over to Vinnie's.
Gonna eat some pizza
with cheeseburgers on it.
What the hell is that?
We're about to be there soon
and I have a feeling this is gonna be
a shit ton of food.
When's the last time you had pizza?
- Last night.
- I'm actually curious to see
if the cheeseburger's gonna be too much.
Too much topping on the pizza.
I mean, I don't know if you can have just.
Come on.
- Come on, Chris.
Keep up with me, man.
Keep up.
Be there in five minutes.
Come on Chris, you can do it.
- [Chris] There she is.
- [Jade] Beauty.
- Coming up on the homestretch.
I see it.
Where is it?
Boom, right there.
(dramatic music)
- My name's Henrik Toncic.
We're at Vinnie's Pizzeria
in Greenpoint, Brooklyn.
My inspiration for the cheeseburger pizza
came from music, mandalas,
melting pots, and madness.
Remixes and mashups.
The best of both worlds.
So we make a Vinnie's
original large cheese pizza.
We grill up the burgers, put the burgers
and the American cheese on the pie
right when it comes out,
pop that back in the
oven, let the cheese melt,
then when it comes out
top it with the bun,
and then add the garnishes which are
ketchup, mustard, white onions,
and pickles.
Here you go guys.
- You ever play spin the pizza?
I don't want to eat it.
He took so much time and
effort to make this so pretty.
Look at how perfect that
just pops out of there.
- I will say this has some weight to it.
- Cheers.
- Here we go.
Let me tell you something.
I don't even know what's happening.
My brain cannot process this food.
- That first bite of a pickle
it just makes you so excited
to eat the rest of this.
- I will say I'm about
halfway through one slice
in the midst of the meat.
Staring to sweat.
This doesn't work if it's not good pizza.
And it is.
- Great pizza.
- I am so pleasantly surprised by this.
(upbeat music)
Jade, come on.
Do not give up on me right now.
- Halftime guys, halftime.
- It's not halftime.
- This is what happens behind the scenes
of Chris's Instagram.
- Here we are just having
the last bite of a slice.
I look up and Jade is.
Even though the slice is
presented a certain way,
you can kind of take it apart.
You're like, oh, I don't want onions here,
I'd rather have the pickle on this bite.
To anyone who called Jade a quitter,
better take your words back.
I kind of feel like
that's all we got in us.
We came, we fought pretty hard.
Jade's asleep.
- Okay.
- We just left Vinnie's.
We got our to go box here.
- It was a little intimidating
when I first got it.
That thing is just like.
It definitely takes a lot of stomach room.
- Like you said, you go in hungry
and you think you're
gonna eat a lot of it.
You get one slice in on that guy,
you're going down.